Follow Langfocus on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram
Hello everyone, welcome to the Langfocus
channel and my name is Paul. Today's
video is a quick video to explain a
concept that I often talk about in my
videos but the viewers sometimes don't
understand and they asked me about in
the comments.
The concept is grammatical case. Case
refers to the grammatical function of a
noun or a pronoun in a sentence. For
example if these are all the words in a
sentence:
ate lion honey badger the a
there two possible messages: this one
"The lion ate the honey badger," or this one:
"The honey badger ate the lion." There are
two roles in the sentence: the animal
doing the eating, and the animal being
eaten. In English we normally know which
role a noun is fulfilling based on word
order. The subject of the sentence comes
*here* and the object of a sentence comes
*here*
Prepositions can also tell us a noun's function
for example "The honey badger
gave a warning to the snake." The
preposition "to" tells us the snake is the
indirect object, receiving the action. But
in many languages word order and
prepositions are not the main ways to
show the function of a noun. The form of
the noun might change or a special ending
might be added to the word to show its
function in the sentence. In English we
do this to show possession like in the
phrase "The lion's defeat." The 's
shows that the defeat belongs to the
lion. And in English we also have
pronouns that change form to show
grammatical case. For example "I robbed
her.  / She robbed me."
"I" and "she" are the subject forms while "me"
and "her" are the object forms. But there
are languages that show grammatical case
much more than English does. The most
common grammatical cases are probably
nominative, accusative, and genitive.
Nominative case generally indicates the
subject of a sentence, which often means
the person or thing doing the action.
Like this in Arabic:  Akala al waladu tufaaHatan
meaning "The boy ate an apple." Here we can
see that the word for boy - "walad" - has an
"u" at the end because it is the subject
of the sentence. And nominative case can
also indicate the thing that the subject
is equivalent to so in this sentence: "Hua
tilmithun" here the word for
student "tilmith" has "un" at the end to
indicate nominative case because it is
equal to the subject. This ending has the
extra "n" sound at the end because it's
indefinite. These kinds of changes
the form of a word to show grammatical
difference are called inflections.
Accusative case generally indicates the
direct object of a verb. In Arabic it has
that use along with some other uses. For
example "Ashrabu al-Haliiba" which means "I
drink milk." Here the word for milk "Haliib"
has an "a" at the end to indicate that
it's the direct object or the accusative
case. Genitive case generally indicates
that one noun is being modified by
another one often to show possession.
"Mudarrisu l-waladi" meaning "The boy's teacher."
Here the word for boy "walad" has an "i"
sound at the end to show possession.
Those are probably the three cases
you're most likely to run into but
depending on the language there are
numerous other cases as well. The dative
case is generally used for a noun which
receives something, something moves
towards that noun.
"Pecuniam puellae non dedii" -  "I didn't give the
girl money." Here the Latin word for girl
"puella" has an "e" at the end to indicate
that she is the indirect object, on the
receiving end of an action. Locative case is
used to indicate a location.
Here's an example from Turkish. "Evde
bir kitap okudum" which means "I read a
book at home." Here the word for house
"ev" has "de" at the end to show that it's
the location where the reading took
place. In English we use a separate
preposition like "at" "in" or "on" to show
location, rather than a case inflection.
Instrumental case is used for a noun
that is used as a tool or a means of
completing an action.
Here's an example from Polish "Piszę piórem"
which means "I write with a pen." The
word for pen "pióro" ends with a
final "o" which is replaced by "em"
because it's the instrument being used
to carry out the action of writing.
Notice that because of that ending, there
is no need to add a standalone
preposition meaning "with". Those are some
of the most common cases. The main thing
to keep in mind is that the form of the
noun or of the pronoun changes depending
on its function in the sentence.
Sometimes cases apply not only to
nouns but also to words that are
connected to them like adjectives and
articles.
Here's an example of an adjective being
inflected for case, this time again in
Arabic. "Al-bintu al-jamiilatu" which
means "the beautiful girl." Here the noun
for girl "bint" has the nominative case
ending and so does the adjective
"jamillah." But the Arab equivalent of "h" at
the end of the world changes to a "t"
sound before the case ending. And here's
an example of articles taking case
inflection, this time from Old English.
"Se cyning" - "the king" in nominative case. In
the genitive case it's "þǽs cyninges"
so the noun is inflicted with the
genitive ending and the definite article
also has a special form in the genitive
case. Words have particular functions in
all languages, of course. But only in
certain languages do they commonly
indicate these functions with changes to
the form of the word. When talking about
languages that do so we often talk about
noun cases or case endings. But remember
that not only nouns can be inflicted for
case but also pronouns, which represent
nouns, and also adjectives, which modify
nouns, and articles, which show whether
nouns are definite or indefinite. I hope
that was helpful summary for anyone who
needed clarification. So the quick
Question of the Day: Do words in your
language change form depending on their
function in the sentence? If you can
think of an example, let us know in the
comments down below." Be sure to follow
Langfocus on Facebook, Twitter and
Instagram, and once again thanks to all
of my Patreon supporters, especially
these extra special ones right here, for
their monthly pledges. Thank you for
watching and have a nice day.
Oh, right, and Happy New Year!
*fireworks*